hey guys i'm ryan right hey there I'm
Veronica six toes and hey I'm Shelley
Meyers so I brought these two ladies
here today because they were here with
me when I saw that the real rejects hit
seventy thousand subscribers hmm and I
thought why not bring on two beautiful
woman for you guys to look at for a
second fine you can look at her more you
look at her for too long we're gonna
have a [ __ ] problem okay yeah give
him a smile dude you're so pretty she is
like the hottest one you know like
they're young no I don't know how I got
all she could do way better than me I am
way way no no she is way out of my
league I have way out of your league
well yeah this is about you guys not my
personal life oh sorry baby spill the
lenovo having it tonight I just wanted
to say a quick thank you we love you
guys if it wasn't for you guys none of
this would be possible because in order
to be seventy thousand subscribers is it
it's you guys so it's not me at all
speaking the truth yeah i'm just really
defining the truth of what it is not
telling you anything new it's it's a
simple fact you guys kick ass that's
pretty much you guys need to exist in
order for me to be at seventy thousand
subscribers what I'm trying to say he's
appreciative of your so it's really all
you you could check out Veronica's
channel she has a good awesome sexy
music in vlog channel does a lot of
covers and she's also a fantastic
vlogger you should check out her editing
skills they're actually rather
impressive all I can I see the system
you do it on hey I movie she does all
that fantastic vlogging on iMovie that's
right hmm families learn from the best
right over here one day will be included
in this video I know right well my
poverty there we're here for anyone to
look at you if you want to get into her
actual personality and mindset you
should check out our video where we
reviewed the poem troll by Shane
cuz when Sam see how deep this woman
thinks what was it lasting the quakes
and quick sun quakes in mm-hmm but
quakes and that's how smart we are so
check out our review of that poem we
apparently did not realize they were
talking about internet trolls oh but
they people were still like but that
shiz deep though oh we got which y'all
came up with we broke me on that no like
we went way past it was actually about
we kind of overthought it yeah and you
can also subscribe to the real rejects
mm-hmm I don't know I don't know why I
sit like this like you're like a free I
know that's like a kind of play here
eventually oh is that what it feels like
to you know not at all baby what this is
a mic it's cuz it's cuz my back pain is
on my left so I always like you know
right so yeah like this sides much
tighter ah like they use a tighter
thanks guys and I didn't totally gonna
do this but we're about to do a reaction
to mortal kombat x reptile gameplay
trailer so yeah i'm always wanted to be
in one of the game come chitters so here
we go baby your dreams gonna come true
cuz they always a really cool trailer
feels so much more entertaining than
regular trailers good do that is so true
did I say you could speak I'm gonna
sub-zero you're at oh oh she might know
something about the game check out this
video coming up